I therefore do hereby declare that
Maurice James George is junior
[Applause]
I just like to thank my fellow
candidates to start with because
actually inhales Odin Raman Regis I
thought we had a very civilized campaign
and it was conducted in the right spirit
in the right spirit of democracy I'd
also like to thank everybody who's
involved in the count tonight
it ran very smoothly and like to thank
everyone the returning officer and all
the counters for the work that they've
done and I'd also like to make a special
thanks to my campaign team who have
worked tirelessly over the last five
weeks to run one of the best campaigns
I've been involved in in qualities I'd
like to thank them all for something of
it
in 2010 I said that I would stand up for
everyone in hail zone in ramen Regis
wherever they're from whoever they are
and I said that again in 2015 and I say
it again in 2017 this country has got
major challenges ahead of it brexit
negotiations making sure our economy is
strong and sound and whatever happens
over the next few hours I pledge to the
people of Hale's in and around and Regis
once again that I will stand up for them
and I will fight for them and I will
fight for this country thank you